now to rochester new york where police
clashed with protesters overnight
over the death of a black man following
an encounter with police this video is
very hard to watch
daniel pruitt died in march after
officers put a spit hood
over his head as he was taken into
custody during a mental health episode
all seven officers involved have been
suspended now tarika duncan reports from
rochester
mr daniel prude was failed
by our police department and he was
failed
by me in a rare move rochester mayor
lovely warren took responsibility for
her role in the investigation
into the death of daniel prude i have
never shied away
from taking action and holding our
police
or anyone that fails in their duties in
our community accountable
that is why i am suspending the officers
in question
today police body camera video shows
officers putting a spit hood over
proof's head
and shoving his face into the ground for
three minutes
while he was naked and handcuffed
mayor warren did not name the seven
officers who were suspended
but says systemic racism played a part
in prude's death
do you think daniel prude would have
been treated differently if he was white
i do why it's just the way that the
system works
she says police chief lauren singletary
originally told her
prude died of an overdose in police
custody she says she did not see the
body camera video until august 4.
i have addressed with the police chief
how deeply
and personally and professionally
disappointed i
am i don't understand why they're not
being charged with murder
daniel prude's 18-year-old daughter
teshiris says paid suspension of the
officers
is not justice for her father's death
they're doing their
hardest to give these officers a slap on
the wrist
and because they did that they're giving
us a slap in the face
and over my shoulder you see a small
memorial here for
daniel prude this is the area where he
was
arrested as for new information that
we're hearing this morning a
spokesperson for the city
tells our affiliate that the new york
assistant attorney general jennifer
summers
asked the city not release that body
camera video back in june
as it would interfere with their
investigation
tony all right rica thank you very much
this is one of those incidents where you
wonder
the police perhaps were not the best
force to show up for what was clearly a
mental health episode
and it's about the mission of police i
don't think they want to be in that
situation no
and not to mention the training of
police they trained for a situation like
that
but you know what guys this is the thing
when you look at that video and you hear
the officers talking
they're laughing they're sort of joking
the inhumanity of how this man was
treated
number one starting with the fact that
he's naked you can tell that he's
unarmed his family had called for help
and the way that he was treated just
when we look at the george floyd video
we think
it can't possibly get worse that video
actually makes me nauseous
because you can see that this man is in
clear distress
and no one is helping him no one is
helping me and the video
the only reason those officers have been
suspended thank god for the video
is because that video came out no there
is a callousness there
if he had a broken leg the reaction i
think would be different than what we
saw
he needed mental health uh intervention
and there's a callousness there there is
it's a double standard we've
covered it in our hour on mental health
it's interesting how the mayor has taken
the position she's taking that
that he was failed and she even said i
failed him yeah
he's taking responsibility